what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper Suite a tiff 2022 for another
interview this one is for the greatest
beer run ever I have some of the cast
here congratulations this is one heck of
a true story yeah
um yeah it's pretty insane so we always
have to do this at a festival because a
lot of movies some people don't know
what these movies are about yet does
anyone want to do a brief synopsis of
the greatest beer on ever yes I'll do
one word yes can you do like one
sentence each actually uh a real a guy
named chicky Donahue
brings a case of beer
so all of his buddies from back home uh
over in Vietnam I feel like I should
have been doing this the entire weekend
with synopsis
talk like this now more efficient keep
talking like this so again based on a
true story here is there any like teeny
tiny detail about the truth of the
situation that shocked you like we get
the broad Strokes in the movie but like
a little detail that either isn't
heavily focused on or didn't make it
into the movie
that they uh
the military win chicky done he was over
there he was over there as a merchant uh
Marine but also
as a civilian as soon as he gets off the
boat
they thought he was CIA because he
dressed in civilian clothing and only
the CIA dressed in civilian clothing in
battle zones and so he just kind of
walked through yeah wherever he wanted
it blows my mind didn't change his
clothes once from what I've yeah I mean
that's pretty cool this bag was filled
with beer he couldn't put anything else
and also when he arrived at the port in
Saigon his first friend that he was
looking for was like 200 yards from him
like
it's in it's just wild feels ordained or
something there's so many things that
happen in the movie and I'm like no way
no way and then I sit there and remind
myself this is based on a true story so
I don't just flat out tell you all to
tell me about your character can you
each give me one asset about them that
you really admired and found especially
creatively fulfilling to tap into
um playing Tom Collins uh is the first
guy that chicky meets on his travels
um and I guess is the real
kind of first sense of
you know at first he's very happy to see
him obviously but then they wake up the
next morning it's kind of like
okay
you you did this crazy thing but it's
time to go home because what what you're
doing could get you killed or in a lot
of trouble tone is not easy I'll I'll
break that up a little what was it like
having conversations with Peter in terms
of like setting the right tone for his
mission because there's a lot of comedic
elements to it but I feel like your
section kind of represents both parts
like a light-heartedness but also you
know basically teasing the danger that's
on the horizon
um yeah I mean
speaking to Tom today the real Tom
Collins and he was saying although you
know it's in such a serious situation
and dangerous situation an endangered
environment
um there is still that camaraderie of
all the guys being in this together and
there's uh you know still a fair amount
of jokes and pranks going on so and
that's what Peter does kind of laces
this whole story which is set in this
like very serious world but laces it
with you know a lot of light-hearted and
uh funny funny moments it's an uneasy
thing to do all right I'll go back to my
uh my previous question an asset about
your character that was uh creatively
fulfilling to play who wants to jump in
next
uh I played Rick Dugan
um who was kind of you know
in the in the trenches on Uncharted
Territory and uh I think logically in
the story it's basically when it really
hits the fan uh when chicky on you know
is becomes cognizant of the ruthlessness
and Peril of of warfare uh but yeah I
mean to speak uh about you know the tone
Pete kind of has a uh sentiment that
you know it's like the quintessential
fairly stamp I think that it like
punches you in the gut makes you feel
and then you laugh at the same time
um and it's just on top of all that just
insane that it's a real life story I
mean
um incredibly remarkable and
heartwarming really
part of what you just described is what
keeps me coming back to his movies
absolutely so it's like a big cinematic
good time but there's real value and
purpose to stories definitely
happy for you guys you're up next
um I play uh Kevin mcloone
uh and Kevin is the only one that uh
isn't found by him he finds chicky in
the middle of the Jungle and like spots
him and so uh chickie didn't intend to
find Kevin uh when he came to the war
which I think is really fascinating wild
um and Kevin is also actually a not a
civilian but like a hired third party
he's not actually serving when chicky
finds him he did serve but then he came
back as like uh he specialized in the
helicopter radar scramblers so he was
like uh um specialist that he was paid
good money to be there and like they
needed that service
um so he was on his way to go fix some
helicopters when he literally saw
chickie on the side of the road in a
bucket hat and was like what the what
the heck is going on right now um yeah
so I thought I I think that's pretty
that's probably the most fascinating
thing about reading a little something
about you catching a beer too yes I did
catch a beer I did I only got one take
that is incredibly impressed was it was
it really it was one take well Peter was
like this is I mean I don't know who
said it they were like this is a really
expensive um shot like a helicopter and
so they were like yeah you get one take
like you better be good and I was like
I'm gonna try my best and I did it I
caught it
um but I didn't know that those old
beers open like you gotta rip him off
like you gotta rip the tab like they
don't open like beers today you work for
the beer yeah so oh God you were all
better off then but I did catch the beer
I did catch the beer very impressive
proud of it
thanks I noted that when I was watching
the movie and then they just sent me the
Press notes recently so I'm reading
through it when I saw it was one take
I'm like [ __ ] it was intense a lot of
pressure
um
yeah I uh I say Bobby kind of like
tail ends the whole thing and similar
you're the first person he sees I'm the
last person he sees I put
chicky on a plane
um
and I I kind of I loved that that was
something that was really easy for me to
get behind
um
you know kind of bringing bringing a
story to close the the the job of the
character within the larger script and
then the the role that Bobby Papas had
in Chickie's life as like one of his
really close friends after that they
live they lived together for a number of
years they got an apartment together
um and yeah I think that was that was
sorry prior to that they lived together
um yeah just kind of bringing bringing
the story home I would say that was
gotta highlight uh Zach a little here
anyone can feel free to jump in whenever
what is something about him as a scene
partner that you really appreciated and
maybe caught you by surprise on set
well I've wanted to tell a story I I
well I told it to Zach but
um I haven't said it to any other press
yet but I first acting role I can't say
it ever again today I know I know I'm
only going to say this is a collider
exclusive
um no I one of the first roles I I ever
played in Middle School on stage was um
Troy Bolton in High School Musical 2.
and some say I might have done it even
better than Zach
um no but I told Zach that like when I
got on when I got on set and he got like
a little emotional because it was like
some like full circle weird thing like I
was literally like in Middle School
playing a character that he originated
and how like we're doing a film together
I don't know it was just wild yeah so it
was a really cool experience for me yeah
that's the same same sort of thing I
didn't play short boat no you didn't any
any kind of music
I played Gabriella okay
um no um but yeah same thing like
watching
his films and stuff and then all of a
sudden my friends are saying oh wait
you're in a movie with Zac Efron's
pretty crazy but
no getting down the first day
um it was very generous very
collaborative to work with like we
shared ideas myself him and uh Pete and
yeah just had such a fun time shooting
shooting those scenes it was brilliant
yeah
in real life he's just such a mean guy
so no but he's he's kind of like tricky
in that sense that he's he's kind of
he's very open and uh you know kind and
receptive I feel to to Direction I had a
chance to work with him on a movie
called a dirty Grandpa loved it really
Art House film like that kind of
seriously I love that one
um but uh yeah he was yeah he killed it
in this really
want to add anything I I agree I mean I
didn't I didn't know what to expect I
hadn't worked with him before uh I was
ready for anything as you always have to
be but I was I was so amazed we just
didn't stop running so that we were
constantly working and finding new
things and and nuances and stuff like
that he was so so generous the entire
time to follow up on that can you give
me an example of something that happened
on set where you thought you knew the
way it was going to go but you found
something in the moment and the scene
changed for the better because of it um
I honestly I think it every single
time we would we would film something it
was a collaborative process between uh
Pete and Jack and myself and and other
elements and things like that we have
Matt Cook can win one of the shots and
we would kind of blend these moments
together in the comedy and the the um
kind of the timing of it which which
where's the serious note so we'd sort of
find that piece together that was really
satisfying we had a similar moment
um with I think like a Thai Royal
aircraft
which is the plane that that Zach gets
on um in the end of the movie and I
think we had like one time because they
were only gonna fire the engines on this
thing once and so it was like a long
shot it's a silhouette shot but that
there was a certain point where they
were like yelling instructions to us and
then we could no longer hear the
instructions was like I'm just gonna hug
you and I think probably you should get
on the plane and he was like yeah I
think I'm gonna do that yeah okay
yeah and I guess I guess it worked it
works really well yeah
um if you had to bring a beer to a
friend that really needed it what kind
of beer would you choose and why
a large one
that's a good answer
high alcohol percentage that is probably
a good answer
um my favorite beer is Moretti we've got
this thing in the UK called Moretti
which is love I don't know if you have
it out there but I just want to make
sure it's nice and cold yeah I don't
think there's anything worse than having
a warm put it in a Yeti stressed me out
a little bit in the movie I'm not gonna
lie yeah carrying around in those bags
they must have just like gone it's gone
PBR man you gotta stick with the theme
PBR or you could all choose my answer
which is Blue Moon because Blue Moon is
a sponsor of the summer
um
so no BS it's legit my favorite beer and
I feel like I was meant to be in the
studio body shots Blue Moon body shots
okay yeah I'm in okay I mean this is my
last interview of the entire Festival
I'm down to drink as many of those I can
after this
um let's do some fun question actually
before I get to the fun questions
because of what goes down in this movie
can you each share an experience where
like a friend either did something
totally out of left field for you that
you didn't expect but was what you
needed in the moment or maybe vice versa
where you went out on a limb to a crazy
extent and you know swooped in for a
friend that really needed you
I just I'm just so nice to everyone all
the time I just I go I go so far out of
my way because I think I was driven to
LAX recently in that yeah
during rush hour and I was like
are we married
I think I thought I was in love after
that I just remember like you're welcome
little small things that my friends
would do whilst I was trying to get into
the business into this industry I was uh
I was working as a laborer and sometimes
work would dry up and I didn't really
have much money and so going out uh my
friends would
pay for my beers and buy me drinks and
stuff so that's all they're always there
for me and always make sure I'm all
right and now I can kind of return the
favor and be I'll look after them yeah
my uh my buddy branner one of my best
buddies he uh he was making his Broadway
debut in New York City and uh I was
flying in to to see it with our other
best friend and my flight got diverted
because of weather so I ended up in
Chicago and not New York and I had like
12 hours until he was like taking the
stage so I rented a car and just drove
through the night or not through the
night through the through the morning
slash afternoon and I got there before
he before he got on stage and uh it was
uh it was pretty epic that's a good one
yeah
yeah it's a film yeah
maybe uh uh my buddy watched my dog this
week something simple like that pet
setting is a serious job big difference
that's all I got okay I gotta say that
yours I want to change my years that was
really moving but um
before I had ever really
been able to do this as a living I had
an acting teacher uh
born Patrice Nadler
um
did I think I owed her like upwards of a
thousand bucks before I I booked
anything I would always come in and be
like hey I'm I'm fresh out I'm gonna
have to stop coming to class and she'd
be like no you're good
um but yeah that would I just I just
wanted to say that if you're going there
I'm going there too because that was
that was
that's something else important people
to have in this industry in the worst
transition ever now some silly questions
I'll go with my would you rather
question first would you rather have to
fake sneeze or fake vomit in a scene
fake sneeze fake sneeze sure yeah face
things you can't pick fake sneeze unless
you can do a convincing fake sneeze
sneezes fake vomit you have to put some
kind of nasty thing yeah
projectile I don't I don't like throwing
up but I'm just like how can someone do
a convincing fake sneeze where it sounds
real I've had some fake vomit in the
thing before I've never had to but you
can just cover it and they can fix it in
post they can get a convention
yeah cheating but also you know that's
we call cheating movie magic I mean yeah
that's why movie movie making is a team
effort where you have a lot of experts
in many many fields
um here's another somewhat silly one
that I love asking there is a zombie
outbreak you can pick two past co-stars
to team up with who do you pick to give
yourself the best chance of surviving oh
[ __ ] throw everyone under the bus right
now too
I'll probably choose the real guys you
know I probably choose oh but oh no real
real people not their characters
or anything else you've done
you're welcome Batman yeah I worked with
Ben Affleck he'd be pretty um badass to
he's a strong man you're He-Man now so
I might have you then can I pick myself
no uh
I mean I feel like Zach would be pretty
good I'm really impressed yeah I think I
like he's because he's got that whole
show
yeah he's just like [ __ ] like yeah he
definitely know he knows a lot about
water as well I've never got to work
with Russell but maybe maybe you just
have Russell Crowe seems like a guy I
think I would get things done yeah right
Gladiator and uh and my mate Paddy
Gibson who's in the new series of shut
up and bone with me just just for the
laughs yeah like you need some yeah I
need someone to keep keep you keep you
happy maybe
that is always a solid pick yeah I would
I would pay
you know that was unfair
did you
get yeah I mean uh some of the guys more
got more training than others but uh
still it was pretty incredible just to
even be a fly on the wall
that is one heck of a movie did you all
give me two people
who got out of it
Zach's Word exactly Kelvin Delgado who's
also in this movie
don't trust him with my life yeah
absolutely he was in the trenches with
uh yeah here's like a somewhat more
serious question here for each of you
what is your absolute favorite part of
the acting process whether it's
rehearsal wearing your costume for the
first time finding Magic on set but then
also what's your least favorite part
where you see some opportunity for
personal growth on a future film
we went from zombies to deep
conversations
uh well something I hate
uh that I could definitely I just I just
don't say anything
um
sometimes you're exhausted and you have
to like do a really challenging scene
and there's something wrong with your
hair or makeup and so people keep coming
you're trying to start the same people
keep coming to you and just kind of like
poking something on your face and that
what you're trying to get angry
sometimes you're trying to get angry and
trying to develop and concentrate on the
emotion of anger while people are like
poking and you're like just kind of make
sure to not direct this at anyone around
me and just keep it keep it in the scene
um but yeah that's always that's always
uh an emotional challenge I think the
best part is just the collaboration you
know with people you get to meet you
know
um because at the end of the day I feel
like it is a director's medium
um and I and yeah just I don't know the
people the collaboration right like yeah
yeah yeah I was gonna say
like what you said about this like magic
when you find this kind of synergy is
synergy the right word where you're just
in the flow you're in you're in
autopilot and it's only until after cut
is called that you're like ah that felt
decent that felt that felt all right
yeah it's cool coming away every project
with like a new group of collaborators
uh and a new uh yeah it's really fun
um I'm trying to think of something I
don't like
um
but something that you want to like
Explore More of to you know I need to
get better at on my like red carpet face
you know when they take your photo and
you don't know if you need a smile or be
serious and like
then like everyone says my eyes get rid
of
squinty
no it's like I'm tired yeah it's like
Clint Eastwood oh okay
that is a good example though all right
I have to let you guys go soon but
before I do guess what I want to ask
about upcoming projects
Masters of the Universe so when you are
bringing back a really popular property
it fascinates me because you want to
give viewers what they want in in that
particular thing but you also want to be
able to add something new to it so what
could you say to the fans out there that
could make them comforted in the fact
that they're going to get what they want
but also something they don't know they
need from that character yet
say all of that right now
um well I mean we're you have some of
the most talented individuals on the
planet excluding myself working around
the clock to make sure that that's
exactly what happens so I think people
can put their trust in that I will take
that
um what else to Shadow and Bone
Shadow and Bones season two
um can you tease anything about how that
show is going to evolve I mean it's a
similar thing everyone's coming back for
more of what they love so much from
season one but you can't just do the
same thing over and over again no
um I think what's going to make season
two uh so great is we're building on uh
the characters but also introducing uh
some great new characters we've got
Lewis tan uh who's in more combos yeah
if you go into your Martial Arts so yeah
he's good and then uh Paddy Gibson uh
who's in the LA
and he's brilliant as as Prince Nikolai
um and yeah we yeah it's just gonna
continue to grow and and develop and um
yeah I don't want to give too much away
I have to give myself in trouble but
I'll just say questions
it's gonna be good I believe you I
believe you uh huge huge huge
congratulations on this movie thank you
for coming by today to everybody out
there the greatest beer on ever keep an
eye out for it and thank you so much for
watching this interview at the supper
suite at Tiff 2022.